l'homme nerfs merci monsieur le
président la question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
ce matin le président de la république
déclaré à nouveau ça va mieux mais comme
pour s'en convaincre il ajoutait c'est
une réalité pas un propos de campagne
les français croit rêver nos concitoyens
doivent rêver lorsqu'ils entendent ça va
mieux alors que le chômage a augmenté de
près de 750 mille chômeurs depuis le
début du quinquennat avec 10,2 pour cent
de chômage ce taux est supérieur en
france de plus de 1,3 pour cent par
rapport à la moyenne européenne
ça c'est une réalité pour plus de 5
millions deux cent mille chômeurs qui ne
pense pas que ça va mieux depuis le
début du quinquennat
ce sont 6 loi sur le temps de travail et
sur le travail qu'ils ont été votés en
quatre ans il serait temps d'admettre
que la politique économique du
gouvernement est un échec
alors que tous nos voisins qui ont
conduit des réformes structurelles ont
vu leur courbe de chômage s'inverser un
taux de 4,5 en allemagne 5,2 au royaume
uni et ce n'est pas je le crains la
dernière loi projet de loi est une
connerie qui risque de changer les
choses
on croit rêver encore lorsque l'on
entend que le président n'est pas en
campagne depuis le début de l'année 2016
nous avons fait les comptes c'est plus
de 5 milliards d'euros qui ont été
distribués comme autant de promesses non
financées pour satisfaire de nombreux
mécontents chaque promesse est
séduisante mais sans financement cela
revient à tromper les français
finalement la seule raison de penser que
ça va mieux c'est que l'alternance
approche
alors monsieur le premier ministre
qu'allez vous faire pour que cette
dernière année de mandat ne soit pas
encore une année de perdue
alors monsieur le premier ministre y at
il encore un pilote dans l'avion
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le député
dominique le mineur vous le savez les
derniers chiffres que nous avons
annoncées en matière de chômage ont
montré une forte baisse la meilleure
baisse d'ailleurs sûr nous regardons les
trois derniers mois près de cinquante
mille demandeurs d'emploi en moins en
catégorie à
parce que c'est cette catégorie là qui
nous intéresse particulièrement montre
bien que nous avons jamais une telle
baisse depuis 2000 15 depuis de pardon
depuis cinq ans depuis 2011
cela montre bien justement et en
particulier en direction du chômage des
jeunes que nous avons alors même que
durant le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
avait augmenté de près 30%
le chômage des jeunes également il vous
devriez vous en réjouir diminue
maintenant depuis 15 mois
puisqu'il ya eu près de trente mille
jeunes qui sont sortis du chômage et je
pense que c'est une chose qui est
essentielle
vous fêtez comparaison au niveau
européen mais je vous invite aussi à
regarder les chiffres du bit et si vous
regardez les chiffres du bit et en 2015
le chômage a baissé dans notre pays nous
sommes quand même le seul pays au monde
qui considère dans les catégories a b c
dans les catégories c vous avez près de
40 % de personnes qui sont aujourd'hui à
temps plein mais qui cherche un autre
emploi donc si on voulait faire des
comparaisons européennes
regardez les chiffres du bit et et vous
regardez bien que justement le chômage a
baissé en 2015 concrètement lorsque nous
disons ça va mieux
regardons quelques indicateurs
économiques nous avons bien sûr
conscience que pour nombre de français
notamment ceux qui sont dans une spirale
du chômage de longue durée ou qui
collectionne des contrats
particulièrement courts et des périodes
de chômage ça ne va pas mieux pour eux
pour leurs enfants et que ce souci
justement de cette précarité
justement nous visons toujours en sortie
mais regardez concrètement les
déclarations d'embauché en hausse les
déclarent les embauches en cdi en hausse
les créations nettes d'emploi encore sur
le premier trimestre en hausse
voici les indicateurs économiques donc
monsieur le député
l'état monsieur renaud gauquelin